earlier today jay inslee said that your
tweets encouraging separation tensley I
said your tweets encouraging liberation
at Michigan Minnesota Virginia where
foam in st. rebellion wondering how that
squares with the the sober and
methodical guidance that you issued
yesterday well I think we do have a
sobering guidance but I think some
things are too tough and if you look at
some of the states you just mentioned it
it's too tough not only relative to this
but what they've done in Virginia with
respect to the second amendment is just
a horrible thing they did a horrible
thing the governor and he's the governor
under a cloud to start off with so when
you see what he said about the Second
Amendment when you see what other states
have done no I think I feel very
comfortable go ahead just to be clear
when you talk about these states
Michigan Minnesota where do you think
that they should live their stay in home
waters or can you talk no but I think
elements of what they've done is too
much I know it's just too much you know
the elements because I've already said
but certainly a second amendment and
second amendment having to do with the
state of Virginia what they've done in
Virginia is just incredible
okay please sir are you concerned though
that people coming out in protest are
going to spread köppen to other people
they're congregating in ways that help
next person if they should not know
these are people expressing their views
I see where they are and I see the way
they're working they seem to be very
responsible people to me but it's you
know they've been treated a little bit
rough